often hear this one is going to be short
I announced quite some while ago that I
was going to be visit visiting Australia
and New Zealand and i would love to meet
up with people down there who are
interested in languages link or whatever
so I now have some dates ok and we've
had these meetups in Europe when I've
traveled in Europe and it's great to
meet up with language Keener's and
exchange use bring your friends whatever
here are the dates okay and I also put
this on my blog the linguist on language
so you can refer back there if you need
to Auckland March the second auckland
new zealand marks the second melbourne
marks the ninth Sydney March fifteenth
and Brisbane March twenty first March 21
so i will leave the link to this blog
post so that if you want to check it out
again you can I would love to meet up
with people again auckland marks the
second melbourne marks the ninth sydney
marks the 15th Brisbane marks the 21st I
hope we get good weather i'm really
looking forward all my life i've looked
at that you know collection of islands
in the South Pacific we're also stopping
at the Cook Islands rura Tonga or
something on the way in I don't know if
there's any and don't think we have any
link members or any people following
this YouTube channel from the cook
islands but if there are we could also
meet up there I'm really looking forward
I'm looking forward to seeing all the
sights and meeting the people and
everyone I talked to who has been down
there says it's great that I'll have a
great time and I'm sure I will so I hope
to see you there bye for now